it can sometimes be tough for soldiers
to re-enter civilian life but when
entire cities are turned into combat
zones by brazen criminals and
hyperactive cops suddenly the transition
isn't so difficult the battlefield
hardline beta delivers a lot of the
things you love and some of the things
you don't love about battlefields along
with a suite of new gear gadgets guns
and getaway vehicles there's a lot to
explore in the beta and we've done a
bunch of the hard work for you in this
starter guide will tell you what guns
are best for each class what vehicles
are best for your situation and what
gadgets to totally avoid follow these
tips and you'll be stacking cache and
tasing faces in no time actually the
Taser is pretty damn useful in close
quarters and not just because it's
hilarious getting a guy on the ground
and may laying him allows you to perform
a quick interrogation which reveals all
nearby enemies on the mini-map if you're
not in the mood to chat or there are
other baddies nearby however just blast
them and be done with it because taste
enemies can get back up and they won't
drop any loot they are carrying which
brings me to my next tip in Blood Money
mode the everyone's steal money real
fast one it is better to rob a man than
a vault vault to take time to loot
whereas a dead dude just drops
bioluminescent cabbage all over the
ground that you can gobble right up hang
out near popular transit lines between
the central stash and the enemy vault to
ambush loaded foes and try to only grab
from vaults when a few of your teammates
are doing the same because it'll go much
faster
speaking of faster once you've got the
loot you've got two choices get in a
vehicle or get to higher ground
scurrying along the street is a good way
to get killed by a lot of things
despite being vulnerable to small arms
fire cars or bikes are your best bet for
safe travel and even the standard sedans
have an extinguisher that you can pop if
you happen to catch on fire there are
some nice long stairways that make great
motorcycle shortcuts or you could add
gravity crime to your rap sheet and just
zoom along a wall parking just outside
whatever parking garage you're raiding
is a good way to downplay your arrival
on the scene while leaving yourself an
option or
quick escape no vehicles nearby then
hoof it to an elevator to gain elevation
then zip line or parachute your way back
towards home base learning routes like
these is key to Blood Money success
because you're gonna need options when
things get fubar which is like all the
time knocking over the big crane creates
a speedy route to the lower vault that
both teams can exploit and working that
frostbite three destructibility on this
wall makes the wee bollards blocking
your way a non-factor unless you're
trying to reach an out-of-the-way sniper
perch though the grappling hook just
isn't worth it deploying it takes as
long if not longer than just running
around and taking the GB stairs for
sniping or for flanking snipers yes okay
but for just traversing the map no
grapple just no now let's talk classes
the operator has one bit of kit that's a
must and that's the self revival
thingamajig for some ridiculous reason
people still don't expect the dead to
rise so just a zombie your way back to
life and bite or resurrect nearby fallen
comrades to make your enemies wonder if
the end times are truly upon them the
g36c is the best weapon for hipfire with
the laser sight and stubby grip and when
you run out of bullets at the wrong time
which you will without the punchy 38
snubnose revolver and give them what for
as for the mechanic and don't you just
want all these cars to blow up with one
splash of your RPG well they won't
mostly but you've got more than one so
reload and Reis plash go anti-vehicle
like never before with both an RPG and a
stinger if the skies are unfriendly but
don't overlook the repair tool yes most
of these cars aren't worth the time it
takes to patch them up but the attack
truck oh yes
and that mobile command post yes please
vehicular firepower and frontline spawn
points have always been two keys to
battlefield success and things are no
different in hardline if you want to get
brawny and live out your cop slash
criminal power fantasy in a particularly
explosive way then let's go for the
enforcer the ballistic shield may look
pretty tempting but it's letting a lot
of ordnance through at this stage so
better leave it behind then again
sometimes the impractical gear can be
the most fun as is the case with the not
super effective but
so badass sawed-off shotgun sure the
870p marine magnum shotgun is way better
but damn if that sawed-off ain't the hot
business look at that business that's
the business and business is booming
alright alright it's not that great the
c4 however is great despite having
entered witness protection and changed
its name to breaching charges these
bombs are vehicles worst nightmare and
if that vehicle happens to be a highly
explosive fuel truck well then they're
everybody's worst nightmare Park this
tanker next to your vault to block off
thieves just don't like stand too close
to it or anything last but not least
we've got the professional which is
basically a sick passive-aggressive burn
against all the other classes when going
pro stick to the rule of recon if you
can acquire a target and kill it in a
second or less use the bolt-action r700
LTR otherwise spring for the semi-auto
PTR 91 or suppress Saiga 308 and hedge
your bets of course you can viably leave
the long-range game behind and just rock
the tec-9 sidearm which is like a
reincarnation of the 93r from
battlefield 4 in that it is totally
deadly at close range slap those laser
tripmines on any vault you come across
to ensure that even in death you can
strike out at UFOs professionals are
also the class that will get the most
out of zip lines but with the flitting
about from roof to roof to gain better
sniping angles give these strategies a
shot and let me know how they work out
for you the comments for these kind of
videos are like bonus tip sections so
contribute below and help us all become
more efficient and deadly criminals
I mean police officers now video game
players